so
in 1984
a 12 year old kid named elon got a
spectrovision computer
and it was a spectrovision 318 it was
one of the basic models of this
spectrovision series
it had this all quirky keyboard that was
impossible to type on and it had this
little hole beside the keyboard
that you could use as sort of a keypad
but it had also this little red plastic
thing that you could put down in the
middle and it became a joystick
and as every 12 year old kid i guess
elon in his first meetings with
microsoft extended basic which was part
of the rom on this one started writing
something akin to the code we're seeing
running on the screen now
by by the time of december that year his
programming shops had gotten way way
better
and
back then in 1984 one way to distribute
computer programs
was through magazines
so what you would do is that you would
print out the code and send it into some
sort of magazine and they would print it
and you would buy the magazine take it
home and then type the code back into
your computer and if you did everything
correctly you could run it
so what you're looking at now is the
code that 12 year old elon
wrote
and sent into pc and office technology
that was printed in the december 1984
edition and i would just like to bring
your attention to his very economic use
of spaces in this one
there are virtually none so everything
runs
continuously so
12 year old elon had learned to trust
his basic interpreter
and when you got to the end of this and
run this thing
you would see the fantastic game blaster
it looks kind of familiar
it was a game where you had a spaceship
that was carrying deadly hydrogen bombs
and had something called status machine
beams that could uh shoot you down it's
a fairly basic game
but i think that some of the ai in this
one still lives on in the tesla
autopilot and this was written by elon
musk 12 years old 1984 he was on the
verge of its teenage years so he's a bit
young to be part of this talk because
this is the marvels of teenage
engineering
and we will be going around the world
meeting loads of kids in their teen
years and see the amazing software that
they built out of their bedrooms
while most other people hadn't even
learned what a computer was yet
so
for those of you who have seen my
previous talks the last few years here
at the ndc know that i tend to go a bit
around the world in these talks
and this time we started out in south
africa which is a bit scary given the
circumstances today
uh usually we've been a lot in america
but this year i'm glad to say that we go
from south africa to the soviet union
so this is the electronica 60 computer
which was made by electronica voronesh
in the soviet union in the 1980s now
this is basically a clone of a western
computer
here in the west this was known as the
digital pdp-11
it was a 16-bit computer with an amazing
64 kilobytes of ram
and this was the computer that the
original tetris game was written on
and tetris was written by
alexey palczyo
this guy
who is not a teenager he was 29 at the
time that
tetris was written
tetris by the way was written in the
pascal programming language which was
sort of the
national programming language of the
soviet union that was the one that was
being used they also had a
soviet translation of that where all of
the key words were in
soviet russian
i'm not sure whether tetris was written
in that or if it was written in
in the
traditional english form of pascal but
anyhow pascal was the language that was
used but
had it not been
for a teenager called vadim gerasimo
who was 16 years old and that's vadim
there in the background on this photo
it's not entirely sure if tetris would
have been the breakaway success that it
ended up to be
wadim
studied at arkadi borashnovki
which was a high school
in soviet russia
and
at this high school he was working with
his maths and computer science teacher
uh doing something else at once as
writing an encryption program for ms-dos
now dmitry palowski who was the
assistant to the father of tetris and
this gets a bit complicated uh
stopped by this high school
and uh bumped into vadim and saw how how
talented he was
programming pascal
on the ibm pc clones they had available
in soviet russia
so palowsky
brought
vadim with them and showed them the
source code to some games he had written
there were these were sort of simple
basic games
and the day after he done that wadim
came back with an ms-dos version of one
of the games that he had written just
overnight
and this was sort of
impressive so
vadim was introduced to the father of
tetris
and he
ported tetris from the electronica 60
to ms-dos
and there was it was the ms-dos version
that made it through the iron curtain
and became the legend that tetris is
today
oops
it's sort of bad when you get malware uh
in the middle of your talk
uh
and this thing has a bit of history to
it
so these days these things are a bit
pesky when you get them
things were a bit
nicer and easier at the beginning of the
1990s
so
i want to tell you the story about a 17
year old punk from san francisco
called neil mcallister
now neil was uh
as many teenagers are um
a bit of a nuisance
his primary hobby was to blow up public
telephones using firecrackers
but he also had an ibm xt clone computer
at home
and
the one thing he used that computer for
was to dial up something called bulletin
board systems now built-in board systems
where like the social media of the day
they wear computers you can phone up
with a modem connected to your own
computer
and if the line was free you were able
to connect this was like a one-to-one
connection it was not a multi-user
system
but he used to hang around us at some of
these built-in boards
and oh at those building boards he met
people who viewed themselves as
lead hackers
and he was a bit annoyed by these people
because he didn't really find it
impressive to write computer viruses
which a few of these people were doing
uh
so
he was started thinking a lot about
computer viruses and then suddenly
there was a really badly named virus
that was written by a doctor theresa
goody
that came on to the scene around april
1990 that spread like wildfire
and
it had the terrible name of aids
which is not something that is really
funny to name a computer wires after uh
it wasn't a particularly good computer
virus either it
it had no none of the smarts that
computer viruses have been known to have
later it didn't wasn't really sneaky at
all it didn't hide out on your computer
in any way it just went on infecting
loads of files and corrupting them
and that virus was written in turbo
pascal
no russian connection as you would guess
with some of the malware today still
written in pascal
so one of the things that annoyed neil
mcallister was that this virus was very
very large in footprint it was 16
kilobytes big so you could very easily
tell if a file was infected or not
because it
instantaneously just
blew up in size
so he wanted to do his own little virus
and he wanted that virus to be
666 bytes
big
or small
you could say
and he named that after his favorite
metal metal band
the legendary metal band def
uh and their album
leprosy
which is another virus but he thought
that was a more interesting virus than
aids which i can agree with them
and this virus sort of infects files
and it becomes active
every year
on
the friday the 25th so every time friday
the 25th appears this happens
so the flash is that hellraiser it was
inspired by the film hellraiser who just
recently came out on your screen and
whenever your computer reboots it does
the same thing over again
so
this was
the leprosy virus
and this was a bit of a special virus
because as you might remember neil
mcallister he was fond of blowing up
public phones
he didn't know anything about computer
programming but he went out and buyed
the peter norton pink shirt book
which at the time was the guide to
programming anything on the ibm pc
ironically peter peter norton at the
time was also making a fortune making
antiviral software
so so he sort of started that circle
going so
this one taught
neil mcallister everything about how to
sort of find the files change them on on
the computer and so forth only one small
detail though
the virus became rather big he didn't
really know how to fit this into 666
parts which was sort of a key to this
thing uh he had going but he found this
he found an article in the december 26th
edition of
pc magazine from in 1989
which had this small little snippet on
how to write your own little c loader
and
neil mcallister had programmed this
little virus of this in c so having this
one instead of the regular c loader
manage them to get away with all of the
sort of argument handling and so forth
and just get the bootstrapping code in
there
and naturally
this is a source code for for this um
for those of you
well versed in c you can see that this
is sort of straightforward c code but he
did a couple of interesting things as
well uh he camouflaged his virus which
he was one of the first people to do so
when he ran his little virus infector
program it just printed out something
that looked like a real error message
but was not it was just a red herring
and he went about
not to infect too many files so it would
stay around be sneaky and it would only
appear with this sort of hell racing
message every friday the 25th the thing
was that he had never heard of open
source software but he wanted to to tell
the world how he made his virus so neil
michaelis was probably the first and
last person in the world to write
documentation for his virus
uh and this is it this is the
documentation for uh for the leprosy
version one virus that he uploaded to
some bulletin board systems around the
world that made all of the antiviral
software developers aware of this virus
within 24 hours and it didn't really
become such a nuisance and they didn't
really affect many people
then he
realized he hadn't managed to get this
down to 666
bytes so he did a second strain
of uh of this virus
uh the leprosy
strain two
and he rewrote that in
in
assembler entirely
managed to get the size down to to what
he wanted
uploaded this to a bulletin board and
forget forgot about it
until a couple of years later
where uh
the 40 hex underground magazine which
was
dedicated entirely to writing viruses in
its first ever
issue had documentation on how the
second strain of the leprosy virus had
managed to be that small and how it had
managed to stay camouflaged for so long
and how it managed to become an epidemic
virus on pc computers back in the early
90s so we can say that this guy he
managed to go viral on social media way
before social media was the thing
oh
breaking into the computer system was
both really easy to do how easy was it
very very easy
so
we're going to go back a few years and
we're going to go back to what enabled
neil mcallister to connect to the
built-in board systems it did uh and the
time where modems were something that
you used now in 1983 the film war games
came out and this sort of
popularized in um in popular culture the
myth of hackers and made hackers sort of
cool
really cool like timothy winslow here
uh timothy was the nerdy kid who went to
the computer room at this school in
every single break and sat around
playing with the computers there
uh
together with neil patrick and a third
that was not
not no longer a teen he had just turned
20.
they started a gang
and
the street gangs
in milwaukee where they were from
had names from
the different streets in the in the town
so they were called
the nines the sevenths sort of based on
what turf they were protecting so they
decided to call call their gang the four
one ones which was the area code for
milwaukee uh on phones which made sense
since they were dialing up using modems
now they met in an uh ibm sponsored
what what can you see now
yep
in an ibm sponsored explorer scouts
camp so explorer scouts exploring
computers rather than wild woods so they
could stay in a safe environment
so they met at an explorer scouts camp
and they started experimenting inspired
by what they did in the wargames film
and um
they wrote a piece of software to sort
of automate dialing up every single
phone number first in the four one one
area code
and see if they could connect to a
computer at the other end
and whenever they connected
these will usually telnet computers
so they knew how to log in you could try
the password admin admin which often
worked at the time
and
they started sort of increasing the
radius
where they tried dialing up numbers and
uh not after long they had
managed to
connect into the security pacific
national bank
baxter travel laboratories canada cement
vault core dynamics which i don't know
what is uh dupa plumbing a taxidermity
shop
but most importantly they
connected to a the sloan kettering
cancer center and then finally the
military plant at los alamos
this naturally sparked the interest of
the fbi
and uh they started hearing sort of
weird clicks on their phone lines and so
forth until one day the fbi showed up at
their houses
uh full-on
thinking that they were going to arrest
some sort of large criminal enterprise
russian spies or whatever finding these
kids uh
and uh
one of them
uh was still a team the two others were
at the time over 18 years old
so
neil patrick went on all the talk shows
talking about this becoming sort of a
celebrity and was uh was
seen as the real world incarnation of
the main character from war games the
others were in a bit more of a sticky
situation because they were actually
indicted with this
but at the time the united states didn't
have any laws relating to computer
crimes or hacking
so in the end they were were charged
with making much malicious phone calls
prank phone calls and they got away
rather easily later that same year the
us got his first loss against computer
crimes and you got these kids to thank
for it
um
[Music]
foreign
is
and i hope the non-norwegian speaking
people among us have managed to read the
subtitles on this this is an
extraordinary example of a 1990s
saturday night national tv entertainment
here in norway
this is a show from 1994 and
and the kids in here dropped out of high
school earlier that year to start one of
the first isps in norway at the time
where nobody had heard about the
internet
uh there was one other company uh
offering internet services in norway at
that time and that company was started
by professor at professors at the
university of oslo
they've got competition from these kids
16 17 and 18 years old
and these kids set up their operation
with regular
sort of
pcs that they had at home with their own
modems and so forth running it out of
their bedrooms to start with
and then moving on
to getting a
more proper operation
they kept on
doing it
with limited hardware for a few years
but suddenly they grew
much much larger
and they wrote all of the software for
this themself
they wrote all of the billing software
all of the connection management things
all of the networking stuff which
you would think is rather hard it's
quite difficult to run a teleco
but when you have the audacity and
and the
the arrogance that you have as a
teenager you can actually go or could go
out and do something like that
in
powertech was sold for an undisclosed
amount of money to
the
leading
fiber company here in norway
but the turnover at the time was
121 million per year
so i guess we could say that the sort of
teenage engineering operation that these
kids were running out of their bedroom
uh
was quite a feat but another thing that
i noticed when looking through these um
these old recordings of
excellent 1990s
saturday night entertainment was
that the skepticism towards the internet
and technology probably was a bad head
of its time
so
1994 uh predicting the future uh there
which is probably something that you do
when you're working for the statistical
bureau of norway so
this might look familiar
uh it might look familiar if you've
played super mario world 3
which is probably why this game is
called dangerous dave in copyright
infringement
so this is a game that was never
released but it's a
part of the dangerous dave
franchise that was started by john
romero which is a fairly well-known name
in the computer games industry
and the first game came out in 1998
at that time romero was 21 which we all
know is not teenage
but the um
the programmer of this
was
16 17 years old at the time and it was
john carmack
and this thing is important because it
changed a lot about how games were
developed and we're going to dive into
some of the technical details so so for
those of you coming to look at code
just sit tight for a couple of minutes
more
because this changed everything and this
was also the start of id software the
legendary game company that would move
on to give us doom but before we can
talk about that we have to have a small
lesson in how computer games are made
so
when you create sort of the levels the
backgrounds uh in these games you do
that using something called a tile sheet
so you have this little squares of
graphics
that are of the same size and then you
go go around and you
sort of tile them out
and you build up this little thing
called a world
uh which is divided into to all of these
little squares
built up of this tile sheet this might
be the same thing as css sprites if
there are any front-end developers among
amongst us this is where it all came
from
and
one of the things that
that came out of this which is sort of
known story is something called adaptive
tile
um
refreshment
which
this is the code for
and the thing here was that uh one of
the inventions that came out of this uh
was that uh you realize how to
keep track of where the characters the
sprites have moved around on the
background so you don't
didn't have to redraw the entire
background you can only redo parts of it
which was a major invention because it
made the games really faster it made it
run more smoothly but that was not the
most important invention in this
so this is the story that wikipedia
brings forward but this thing enables
something entirely different
because
the ibm pc did not really have very good
um hardware for doing graphics
but one of the changes was that
on the extended graphics adapter you had
the possibility to increase the screen
size beyond what was displayed on the
screen so you would get what you're
seeing here you would have the viewport
which was what you saw on the screen
and then you would have this little
piece
often on the edges of the screen
and
this
was one of the things that john carmack
discovered that he could add this to the
to the ends of the screen and then he
can
manipulate the screen address what the
video graphics card in the pc would show
he could manipulate to move this to the
sides
and then he just drew two lines of these
tiles off and on the edges of
the screen
and then used his tile refreshing
technique
to update this which
made him
make a smooth side-scrolling game that
had never been possible on the ibm pc
before
and even if wikipedia focuses on the
story about the adaptive trial refresh
the guinness book of records in 1999
1991 sorry gut is right by naming
commander keane and the invasion of the
vorticons
as the first ever smooth scrolling pc
game
that's worth
a round of applause guys
so
that allowed them to run advertisements
like this one the ibm pc out shown the
amiga and i
looking around i guess some of you in
the room had amigas
back in the days oh yeah there were a
few hands coming up there
and there were two computers that
competed at the time uh
that that on paper were sort of similar
you had the commodore amiga
and you had the atari sd
what was common between these two were
that uh both computers had the motorola
68 000
processors in them
but the amiga was technically superior
to the atari and we could easily see
this by doing a side-by-side comparison
of the legendary diagnosis game
shadow of the beast this is a game from
1989 it was not written by teenagers
but you have on one side with the
commodore logo underneath the amiga
version and you have the atari st
version on the other side and you can
tell the difference uh this is the same
processor the difference is that the
amiga had loads of graphics processors
that made this look
terrible on the atari this was the best
they could do that was the best that
adults could make after the game on the
atari st and one of the reason was why
this fits so nicely side by side was
that they didn't even have the
processing power to play any music on
the atari version so all the music we
heard was from the amiga version of this
it would take a teenager to change this
this is the atari st game enchanted lens
released by thalion software
1990.
this game is programmed by 17 year old
swede nicholas teselle
and we have all heard the stories of
john romero as we just heard who has
been sort of
talked about as one of the entrepreneurs
who really changed game programming
nicholas tissot
is an unsung hero
this sounds rather funky but we have to
move on so we have to talk about the
atari st
uh the atari sd uh came with two
different kinds of screens
you had the option of by choosing the
high resolution black and white screen
that gave you a resolution of 640
times 400 pixels with a refresh rate of
71 and
a quarter
hertz
that doesn't really sound that amazing
but at the time that was the best you
could do or you had the option of
getting the color
variety which had the possibility of
displaying 16 colors at the time out of
a total 512
colors it was capable of using but you
have to sacrifice that for resolution so
you only got 320 times 200 as as your
resolution at 50 hertz and the 50 hertz
is is important here
that's the switching rate of the
electricity grid here in europe
if we go to the united states
that increases to 60 hertz and it was
also capable of
displaying the screen at 60 hertz but
what happened then was that it was
vertically stretched
like this
and this takes us back to
to school guys we have to go to the
school of teaching engineering again to
learn about
vintage technology and the kinds of
screens we were using before lcd and
flat screen monitors were around
so
uh you might have seen this
at museums at your parents house or
somewhere else but this is sort of what
the television used to look like back in
the days this was probably the set that
people looked at the 1990s program that
introduced powertech to the world back
in 1994. this is a cathode ray tube it's
a pretty pretty pretty
great name for something it sounds
really really cool it's re even cooler
in
reality so if you look at an
intersection of something called a
cathode ray tube you have this thing
this is the screen
and
at the end of this um
the end without the cat
you have a ray gun a cathode ray gun and
wow doesn't that that sound cool to have
in your living room you have an actual
ray gun in there so you have this
cathode ray gun that fires a ray at an a
node and then hits the fluorescent
screen at the end
which
switching the electricity on and off or
something like that enables it to draw
an image onto the screen
and then you have really powerful
magnets other cool stuff you can add to
this
that
enables you to sort of bend that ray to
position where on the the fluorescent
screen it hits which
enables the television to draw an image
from the left hand uppermost corner
going to the right moving line by line
down and you end up with
something that appears on the screen
now
this was common knowledge to to this
bunch of teenagers this is a gang from
sweden called the care bears
yeah
that that's a great name isn't it uh
nicholas teselle as i talked about is
one of the people the one with the with
the red ring around them the others are
anders nielsen nicholas mount quist and
uh andreas circus
these guys were wizards with pushing
their atari sd computers to the limits
and beyond the limits
because
using those different resolutions and
refresh rates that the different screens
had
they were able to do something amazing
and
right now we're going to go through the
most mind-boggling part this is also
where we will see the weirdest code
today so if you don't understand the
thing of this
no worries it took a 17 year old suite
to figure all of this out so uh you have
an excuse there
motorola 68 000 assembler ladies and
gentlemen so
the red line on the screen here is that
cathode ray moving from the left to the
right and for every single line it drew
on the screen the the processor had 512
clock cycles to perform things then it
moved on to the next line
and if you knew
how many clock cycles each machine code
instruction took you could start
counting
where along the line you were and that's
exactly what nicholas teselle was doing
so when he had gotten to this position
where the red line is now he did
something interesting
he figured out what if ask yourself the
question what if i switch the screen
into 71 hertz
then wait a couple of clock cycle then
switch it back to 50 hertz again what
happens then
lo and behold
the left hand side border the big black
border around the screen disappears and
he gets a larger canvas to draw on
who would have known
then you just wait and move along until
you come a bit further along the line
and
then you need to do something different
to avoid the television screen from
exploding you have to do the switch
again
and this actually happened before they
figured out how to do this they had a tv
set explode in his bedroom
i kid you not
so
he did this and when
the
refresh came all the way over to the
other other end
he switched to 60 hertz
waited as
millisecond and then went back to 50
hertz again low and behold the right
side border opened up and then he just
had to do some more
uh figuring out to do and to stabilize
it all and then
he could just move on to the next step
and when he created a long list of
different variations of doing this and
did this for five to eight lines
he was able to offset the screen
change where
the video chip in the computer started
drawing drawing the screen to actually
and
hold tight to your seats now
do software-based
hardware scrolling on a computer with no
graphics hardware
i'll say that again software-based
hardware scrolling on a computer with no
graphics hardware
which
enabled him to move the screen smoothly
sideways which was exactly the trick he
pulled off in this game
for italian software that he developed
when he was 16 years old 17 years old
so august 1st
1981 something really important happened
and nothing to do with computers it had
everything to do with music
mtv launched
uh
and mtv would go on to change popular
culture and it would naturally influence
computers as well um mtv had a show it
was the longest running show in mtbs
history called the party zone that was
on every saturday night in europe it
launched in 1988
and it
presented modern dance music and things
like this psychedelic video clips from
midnight and until
two or three in the morning
after which it was time to come down and
the chill out sun came on
so
this
inspired some people to do something
interesting
[Music]
so this is on the commodore amiga it's a
demo made by a group of teen programmers
known as spaceballs they're from norway
from
eastfall holden area
and uh yeah
someone from there in the room tonight
that's good uh and they did this it was
sort of a music video and uh this was
uh
was something totally new at the time
because
people had had scroll text and so forth
and
so such but this time someone actually
made something that resembled something
that you could see on mtv and mtv
actually went on to show this at the
party zone as well so they sort of went
full circle there and the guy who
programmed this was the 16 year old
we're about to meet now
[Music]
so this is 16 year old paul andre
anderson
he was the programmer behind the thing
we just saw
and uh for those who are familiar with
what they did
this is the actual
footage from where when they created the
follow-up
to to what we just saw so
when they had made the first one it was
a breakaway success and then they had to
make the sequel to follow up that and he
took his girlfriend who is the brunette
here and her friend out
set him up in front of a a white wall on
their local school and just put them
uh sing hallelujah by dr alban i believe
and just had him dancing
and this is the original footage that
they used to make
this which came out the year after the
state-of-the-art thing we just saw this
is called nine fingers was released
december 29
and what paul andre anderson did when he
was he had turned 17 at the time was
that he wrote digitization software that
took the videos and created turned it
into the vector graphics we see here
that's pretty amazing work for a 17 year
old i would say and this
was just just amazing and we'll come
back to him in just a second but we have
to do we have to
skip across to england and meet
dylan kurt berth
who is an interesting character
dylan cutberth uh got himself a set x
spectrum computer um when he was around
13 years old
and
one thing he didn't have was that he
didn't have any games for that
so he had to write his own games
uh he said he wasn't even from yorkshire
he wasn't a yorkshire man but he acted
like one
um no monty python fans in the room i
guess um
oh you were lucky
uh
so
so he started writing games for his zx
spectrum computer which was a
fairly
limited computer compared to the
commodore 64's and such that uh and
apple twos that programmers in
in the
united states grew up programming so he
learned a lot about
living with limited hardware
and when he was around 16 years old he
wanted to get a job in the games
industry
so
he
wrote a
little piece of software for his
commodore amiga which he had acquired at
the time
with a rotating argonaut software logo
put it on a diskette mailed it to
argonaut software the day after that
arrived there he got a phone call and
was offered the job
and argonaut software were known for
putting 3d engines in just about
everything at the time
and when dylan cuthbert started working
there he did as any curious teenager
would do he would start with set to
reverse engineer something pulled
something apart and the thing he was
said to reverse engineer was the
nintendo game boy because argonaut
software wanted to get in with nintendo
and make
games for nintendo's but they didn't
have any development kits
so he made his own development kit for
uh for the nintendo game boy and wrote a
3d engine which was the thing that
organelle software did
only that organo software were mostly
adults dylan cutbert was a 16 year old
kid
and he made this game
called x for the nintendo game boy
and got noticed by nintendo so
nintendo flew him over to
japan
where he got to work with the teams at
nintendo to create this game and this
game is known as star fox
and it was the first sort of real 3d
game for the super nintendo
entertainment system
uh
you had sort of
3d like games such as mario kart that
came out the year before this but that
was due to a system in the nintendo
called the mode 7 graphics
which which
changed the width of the screen on every
single scan line moving down does that
sound familiar to you to you a lot this
was actual 3d graphics with with real 3d
polygons and so forth and to make this
happen on the extremely limited software
that was in
in the nintendo entertainment system
they had to make a special chip that
went on the game cartridge that you
plugged in and it was called the fx ship
that did all of the 3d calculations that
were possible for this and that ship was
designed by oregon argonaut software
dylan cuthbert was one of the lead
designers of this he had turned 18 at
the time and the ship is known as the
mario chip it's the mathematical
argonaut rotation and input output chip
uh so that ship uh went in a few games
uh one of the games nobody noticed was
this one
uh winter gold
was immensely delayed uh this was uh
meant to come out around the olympics at
lillehammer 1994 didn't come out until
uh where at which time people most
people had forgotten about the super
nintendo entertainment system then moved
on but does this look a bit familiar
this is programmed by paul andre
anderson and he's using the same
techniques as he used for programming
his amiga a few years
earlier now he was 19 and he created
this game and it was a 3d game that
looked like nothing like star fox
and the 3d graphics here were much more
more at once thank you uh much more
advanced and the reason is that this is
not really a 3d engine he was using the
techniques from his nine fingers
production to create a 3d video or
3d video that you moved through like uh
on rails game so that's winter gold for
you
so what about those having even more
limited hardware to play around with
again this is the game shadow of the
beast in the amazing version that was
made for the commodore 64. uh personally
i think this looks better than the atari
at least the official atari version of
this and the commodore 64 was
a amazing computer but as people started
pushing it to its limits and beyond its
limits
the limited amount of memory in the
commodore 64 became a problem
a problem that danish teenager henning
andre anderson sought to solve
he went under the alias einstein and he
created the einstein assembler for the
commodore 64.
this was something known as a cross
assembler
that meant that you wrote your code on a
commodore amiga you had a special cable
that you connected between your
commodore amiga and your commodore 64
and you would com
assemble the code onto the commodore 64
so you could use the entire memory as
your assembler didn't take up any memory
footprint
he was around 16 years old when he wrote
this
he distributed that along with
schematics for making that cable you had
to make the cable yourself at the time
it cost you 700 danish kroner
50 more if you were to use it with a
television screen that was sort of a
joke because he was leaked uh that would
be 1200 danish chronos today and you had
to make the cable cable yourself but at
least they invented this thing
another legend
jordan mechner he is
mostly known for
for doing the prince of persia games
which he did when he was a bit into his
uh
his twenties
i don't i don't think that's a very
interesting story the source code is on
github there is a book written about it
if you want to learn more about the
prince of persia games it has even been
made into a movie if you if you don't
like reading books i want to talk about
his game
death bounce
which was never released
which he created when he was 16 years
old and the interesting thing with
jordan mechner was that he kept
meticulous journals writing down
everything he ever did
so he kept a log of writing this game
and
it starts out february 7th 1982
where he has this idea he has written
read something about to create
producing random dots in a computer
magazine sparks an idea in his head that
he wants to turn this into a game uh
then he starts thinking about how much
money he can make if he
thinks that if he sells a thousand
copies he'll make four hundred four
thousand five hundred dollars if he
sells five thousand that will be twenty
two thousand five hundred
he is about to strike gold he is about
to become rich and he motivates them to
move on creating this game uh he
moves on to sort of stumble upon all of
these sort of challenges you have uh
writing this game in basic is too slow
he has to move on to do something in
assembler instead a few days days later
he has to figure out how to do dual page
animation uh to not make it flicker but
he has to discover all these things for
his own because there was no internet
around but he sits there in his room
writing this game on his own and
creating it and for as you can see the
result is rather rather amazing and this
all comes from him reading this issue of
creating computer creative computer
magazine from january 1981
and this is the article he he
he came across which explains how to
create random dots but the little text
down in the right hand corner which you
probably can't read says since these
three teams were written in basic they
run rather slowly
an obvious enhancement would
be a machine language
implementation which is exactly what
jordan mechner did he taught himself
assembler programming to do this and i
find it sort of soothing
that
he has this journal entry that he has a
to-do list
and he needs to
finish the game module clean up the code
test test test
and then just do the
last feature finish top add the cursor
and so forth so teenage engineering in
the bedroom of jordan wagner was exactly
like our projects at work uh there was
always something left to do and a to-do
list that we never get to finish
this is not a teenager this is
11 year old chris mejira
and he wrote a game for the apple ipad a
few years back
uh which is the game you see here
he went on to give a ted talk about what
he did and in that ted talk he
he was
asked the question how did you ma manage
to do this and he said i just sat down
and wrote wrote the code
which is where you build things you sit
down you write to code
there isn't much code out there
so
he might have had some help might this
is something i found on this github
he has
at least ambitions because this is sort
of a swift code
for
ios
hello world thingy
but he is going to destroy the world
hello world get destroyed and i think
that says something about the ambition
of
of people starting out writing their own
own code
and uh
that got me thinking
because
the stories that i've told today
are mostly from a very specific era of
our computing history
and most of these things are about kids
that came of age around the early 90s
sadly there are no girls in here and i
looked i tried to find the stories about
girls who did this there were none
and there were a couple of things
happening at the time
at the time at the end of the 1980s was
where things changed from i.t
becoming a voice
thing to do
from having loads of women employed
there the amount of women employed in
the it industry dropped
sharply at the end of the
1980s early 90s
having computers as home were a boy's
toy
which doesn't make sense at all
today we see some of the stories and i
try to find some more current stories
about teen
inventors and luckily there are
quite a few girls out there doing
amazing things coming up with amazing
ideas
to to realize
and being able to assemble teams around
to actually put those ideas into
becoming reality
but i had to draw the line somewhere and
i would wanted to tell the story about
kids going out and doing this on their
own
and doing all of it on their own
uh from
sort of
that teenage go for it spirit that we
all felt once
and
to
be sure that we can spark that spirit
again it's really important that we
encourage
kids these days where the computer comes
with everything pre-installed you don't
have to sit down write your own software
you have the app store so you don't have
to type anything in from a magazine to
have some some simple game running on
your computer and you don't really have
to learn about how the computer actually
works
that we spend time
with kids
teaching in them about how computers
work and how
code works and teaching the kids how to
code because that is
important
i want to take you
to
lakeside high school
late 1960s
and i want to tell you the story about
two other pupils at school
lakeside high school had gotten a
computer room that the mothers at the
school had
sort of petitioned for it getting and
they had a computer terminal there which
allowed you to work against a central
computer somewhere else and two of the
kids at that school were so
amazed by this computer
that they broke into their high school
computer room and used that computer
in the evenings
eventually they were caught
first they were expelled from the school
but then the headmaster realized that
maybe just maybe these kids have
something to contribute
so he gave them a challenge
they could have their computer time back
if they solved a problem for the
headmaster
if they could
solve his problem that he had two people
working and the entire summer through to
set up the time schedule for the next
semester they could use the computer
room as much as they wanted
and these two kids went in there
day and night working on this problem
and they managed to solve it one of them
also wrote a little easter egg in there
so he could sit next to the girl he was
fond of at his high school
and they got their computer time back
those two were bill gates and paul allen
and it's a tale of ingenious teenage
engineering that went on to become
something much
much bigger
and i think that's an inspiring story to
end with to see just how far
teenagers with the right kind of
motivation can
get ladies and gentlemen this have been
the marvels of teenage engineering have
a great ndc party and thank you all for
for coming
and i would love to talk to all of you
about this later on so
you'll find me around thank you
[Applause]
you